[Musik]
anflug auf ein schiff dass es so kein
zweites mal auf der welt gibt
ja
solitär
große verlegeschiffe für kabel eins auf
der welt
er wollte ihr besuchen um zu schauen wie
geht aber noch zwei der umstrittenen
pipeline voran hier 45 minuten flug
südlich der schwedischen insel gotland
verlegt die mannschaft auf dem rund 300
meter lange spezialschiff die
gaspipeline und kämpft um die zeit denn
bis ende 2019 soll die neue verbindung
zwischen russland und deutschland fertig
sein
auf dem lande deck erwartet und
sicherheitspersonal das auch bei
schwierigsten wetterverhältnissen die
landung absichert das heißt bei einem
orkan bei windstärke 11 hohem wellengang
und schlechter sicht müssen
versorgungsschiffe passen
die hubschrauber fliegen dann immer noch
weiter von oben ist gut erkennbar dass
die solitaire eine schwimmende fabrik
ist die sicherheitsanforderungen für die
besatzung sind sehr hoch auch für uns in
40 bis 50 meter tiefe in der ostsee hier
verlegt werden das ist eine sehr
sensible art des transportes für gas und
es ist auf jeden fall eine sehr
umstritten
wir wollen aber auch schauen auf die
technik wie eingesetzt wird und auf die
fragen der energieversorgung für europa
denn diese energieversorgung europas
verändert sich durch nord stream 2 die
zweite große erdgaspipeline nach nord
stream 1 die im november 2011 eingeweiht
wurde
das ruft die politik auf den plan
us-präsident trump lässt keine
gelegenheit aus das projekt massiv zu
kritisieren für ihn entsteht durch nord
stream eine hohe abhängigkeit europas
von russischem gas mit deutschland geht
er dabei besonders hart ins gericht
im juli 2018 klagt er deutschland wird
total von russland kontrolliert die
bekommen 60 bis 70 prozent ihrer energie
aus russland und dieser neuen pipeline
wir müssen über die milliarden und
abermilliarden reden die die deutschen
an ein lang zahlen gegen dass wir die
amerikaner sie schützen sollen doch auch
in europa und anliegende nachbarländern
bleibt die pipeline bei einigen ein
rotes tuch stream 2 nutzt deutschland
nicht jedenfalls nicht in puncto energie
sicherheit dass hilfe der eu nicht und
auch nicht der ukraine
wer soll denn nun wirklich interesse
daran haben die meinungen in der
europäischen metropole brüssel gehen
weit auseinander zumal hinter nord
stream die quasi staatliche russische
gazprom artig steht
sie setzt sich massiv in den
europäischen institutionen für das
projekt für die kanzlerin gehört die
pipeline zur energiewende
ich weiß selbst meine freunde in der svp
sind über north stream alles andere als
einer meinung aber wir werden wenn wir
aus der kohle aussteigen wollen mehr gas
benutzen müssen noch für eine brücken
zeit und das bedeutet war werden wir
russland als fälle nicht ausschließen
nord stream 2 führt vom nordwesten
russlands zum deutschen greifswald in
mecklenburg vorpommern und folgt damit
der ersten partner nord stream ein
rund 1200 kilometer lang während der
politische streit also weiter geht
müssen sich die arbeiter auf der solitär
beeilen denn das wetter wird immer
schlechter wird die see zu unruhig muss
das verlegen der rohre unterbrochen
werden
das kostet eine menge geld und bringt
den zeitplan durcheinander
doch genau das darf nicht passieren
beginnen die herbststürme in der ostsee
erst ruhen die kräne und auch die
schweißarbeiten die finden im bauch des
schiffes statt dort wo rohre im
gesamtgewicht von 22.000 tonnen lagern
der niederländische kapitän kenny hoben
fragt sich oft bin ich kapitän eines
schiffes oder einer fabrik in jedem fall
lastet eine enorme verantwortung auf dem
mann aus der holländischen provinz der
so unbedingt zur see fahren wollte das
ist die größte herausforderung für ihn
auf der solitär kenny haben zeigt auf
die arbeiten an den rohren und sagte es
komme auf unbedingte präzisierungen beim
zusammenbauen alles müsse exakt passend
millimeterarbeit eben bei der
komplexität der arbeit frage ich wie
können sie da sicherstellen
hundertprozentige qualität zu erreichen
und er antwortet es ist eine genaue
qualitätskontrolle nötig
da muss nicht nur jeder handgriff sitzen
sondern auch jeder handgriff wieder und
wieder überprüft werden
ein automatisches fest verfahren am ende
ist der schlusspunkt und der garantiert
dann hundertprozentige sicherheit
[Musik]
die arbeiter auf der solitär arbeiten
jeweils fünf wochen und haben dann fünf
wochen frei alle sind spezialisten auf
ihrem gebiet ihre freizeit verbringen
sie an bord im fitnesscenter oder vor
dem fernseher das bier am abend müssen
sie sich übrigens sparen an bord
herrscht absolutes alkoholverbot und das
wird auch immer wieder überprüft sonst
heißt es runter von bord bereits nord
stream 1 war umstritten
der russische präsident putin und
kanzler schröder verteidigte die partner
im jahr 2004 gegen kritik schon damals
sprachen kritiker von einer abhängigkeit
die entstehe wladimir putin dazu fragen
sie doch bei den unternehmen und den
fahrplan vertrag unterzeichnen
ob die zusammenarbeit nötig ist sie
werden ja sagen und das kaum aus
innenpolitischen gründen bei der
vertragsunterzeichnung im juli 2004
waren auch die deutschen firmen
wintershall und e.on mit von der partie
jan schröder bestritt nachteile für
andere länder
diese zusammenarbeit ist gegen niemanden
gerichtet sondern dient deutschen
interessen und dient russischen interest
und ich wüsste nicht was daran falsch
sein sollte angela merkel diskutiert
damals noch als cdu vorsitzende die
innenpolitischen bedenken mit vladimir
putin auf russisch sie wird am 22
november bundeskanzlerin und befürwortet
die partner deutlich
es ist ein strategisch wichtiges projekt
und ich befürworte dieses projekt
außerordentlich und es ist
energiepolitisch natürlich von
allergrößter bedeutung
aus dem russischen wyborg baut das
konsortium ab dem 6 april 2010 die
pipeline bis ins deutsche lubmin mit
mehreren schiffen auf dem meeresgrund
von dort konnte das gas verteilt in
andere pipelines fließen
auf der brücke der solitär arbeitet
neben kapitän kenny hoben der
chefingenieur was ist die besondere
aufgabe auf der solitär für einen
ingenieur das ist ja eine komplexe sache
hier auf diesem schiff ja das kann man
wohl sagen komplex ist es aber ich habe
ein gutes team
50 bis 60 leute stehen mir zur seite
um diesen job zu machen sie sind
eingeteilt in vier gruppen ingenieure
auf deck verantwortliche für den
transport für die paar plan und für die
elektrizität
ich bin also nicht allein ich habe ein
gutes team um mich seine hauptaufgabe
ist es dabei
diese teams zu koordinieren wenn die
rohre zusammengeschweißt sind werden die
anschlüsse mehrfach überprüft das gas
muss schließlich unter sehr hohem druck
über die lange strecke transportiert
werden
der betonmantel drumherum dient dann die
gas gefüllte pipeline am meeresgrund zu
halten
die einzelnen dann miteinander verbunden
verschweißt und eine qualitätskontrolle
muss sicherstellen dass hier keine
fehler vorliegen
das einlegen in die ostsee in 40 bis 50
meter tiefe ist nicht ohne
schwierigkeiten bei dieser geringen
tiefe kann es sein dass eine geringe
bewegung des schiffes sofort ein schaden
an der partner
auch der ort der verlegung muss
zentimeter genau passen denn die
pipeline darf sich nicht verschieben
durch das zusammenschalten mehrerer
satelliten navigationssysteme gelingt
das mit einer toleranz von unter 5
zentimetern
wenn die nun verbundenen rohren als
fahrplan ins wasser gleiten wird
deutlich die pipeline hängt nicht an dem
schiff sondern umgekehrt das schiff ist
teil der pipeline
daher auch die enorme kraft des antriebs
8 6 zylinder motoren entwickeln 70.000
ps diese sind auch nötig um in bewegter
see die verlegung präzise zu steuern
auf der brücke überwachen auch nicht
kapitän und steuermann den kopf sondern
ein dutzend spezialisten kontrollieren
jeden winkel der solitaire das besondere
an einer pipeline verlegen
einerseits hat man natürlich ein schiff
an ein sehr großes sogar das was
natürlich mit aller regeln und und
internationaler sachen zu tun hat von
von von der schifffahrt
andererseits hat man zu tun mit mit
einer fabrik sozusagen wir produzieren
ja diese pipeline und diese zwei welten
muss man ein bisschen kombinieren als
als gärten sind hier über 400 menschen
an bord sehr unterschiedliche menschen
in der führung dieses schiffes wie sie
oder auch unten als arbeiter bei der
pipeline wie hält man die zusammen das
sind unterschiedliche mentalitäten sie
haben ja viele nationalitäten hier auch
an bord ja das stimmt aber irgendwie
funktioniert das eigentlich sehr gut
obwohl es sehr viele nationalitäten sind
manchmal zwölf bis sogar 20
nationalitäten
das geht eigentlich sehr gut ich weiß
nicht ob das vielleicht zu tun hat mit
mit der sache dass das alle hier sind um
die arbeit zu machen um sein geld zu
verdienen
sowieso wenn man solche arbeit macht hat
man eine sehr besondere mentalität weil
sonst verlässt man nicht sein zu hause
um ihre wochenlang
eine pipeline oder oder auf einem schiff
zu arbeiten vom beginn der planung an
forderten die ostseeanrainer hohe
umweltauflagen das besondere problem der
see besteht in kriegsmunition einer
geringen wassertiefe und einem
empfindlichen ökosystem angst vor
möglichen schadstoffen gab es bis
zuletzt doch nach aussagen von nord
stream 2 hat das unternehmen alle
umweltauflagen eingehalten
hier beginnt noch zu drehen zwei im
nordwestrussischen kinder set zehn
fußballfelder groß ist das gewirr aus
rohren verbindungsstücken ventilen und
verdichtern das gas das hier ankommt hat
bereits eine lange strecke hinter sich
hier rund zweieinhalb stunden von sankt
petersburg entfernt geht das gas was aus
libyen kommt über 3000 kilometer
unterwegs ist quasi in die pipeline nord
stream 2 in die ostsee hinein und dann
sind es noch einmal 1230 kilometer bis
lubmin in mecklenburg vorpommern
dort wo das gas in deutschland ankommt
die technischen voraussetzungen hier
sind ausgesprochen anspruchsvoll das
ankommende gas wird aus einem gewirr von
rohren in die pipeline geleitet unter so
hohem druck dass es 1230 kilometer weit
durch die ostsee fließt in die es hier
in der nabu geleitet wird der großteil
der arbeit ist getan 800 menschen
arbeiten hier holländische und
norwegische firmen drängen im winter
fall nämlich hier temperaturen von minus
30 grad an
wie organisiert chefingenieur silberg
das scheinbare chaos ihr locker das sei
die herausforderung an der sache aber
das mache den spaß an einem solchen
projekt auch aus wenn verschiedene
unternehmen aus unterschiedlichen
ländern daran arbeiten dass eine
besondere aufgabe das zusammenführen von
verschiedenen mentalitäten und
nationalitäten
das mache den spaß der spaß bei den
anrainerstaaten der pipeline hält sich
nach nord stream einst auch bei
nordstream zwei politisch in engen
grenzen
durch die direkte verlegung nach
deutschland scheint es nur zwei
profiteure zu geben russland und
deutschland offener widerstand kommt
besonders aus den baltischen staaten und
polen
vor allem aber auch aus der ukraine
die bisher von den gebühren aus der
pipeline in ihrem land profitiert beim
besuch der deutschen kanzlerin in liter
und war noch stream zwei zentrales thema
litauen lehnt die pipeline rundweg ab
die kanzlerin hält dagegen
angesichts der ziele die wir im
zusammenhang mit der klimapolitik
erreichen müssen werden wir auch unseren
erdgasbedarf er vergrößern
das north stream zwei projekt ist
deshalb eines was ich für sinnvoll halte
litauens präsidentin grybauskaite
wir sehen es als geopolitisches und
nicht als wirtschaftspolitisches projekt
auch nicht als energieprojekt unsere
position hat damit zu tun dass wir
schlechte erfahrungen gemacht haben wir
wissen was es bedeutet wenn man von
einem einzigen energielieferanten
abhängt der russland heißt das war auch
eine so wie ich es verstanden habe eine
der grundbedingungen für dieses projekt
das es für die ukraine eine lösung gibt
das auch weiterhin dort transit
stattfinden wird und wenn wir uns vor
augen führen dass wir den nächsten
ungefähr zwölf bis 15 jahren in europa
mindestens 25 prozent des
energieverbrauches nicht gedeckt haben
schon der muss durch importe gedeckt
werden und hier wird nord stream
ungefähr 55 milliarden kubikmeter aus
ungefähr der energieversorgung von 5 26
millionen haushalten entspricht
beitragen können dass 70 bis 80
milliarden kubikmeter müssen irgendwo
herkommen und die reine mathematik
spricht dafür dass auch die ukraine
weiterhin einen transitkorridor nach
europa sein wird
eine alternative zur pipeline gas
unterstützen die gegner noch streams
besonders flüssiggas das tankschiffe
befördern
größter profiteur
die usa wir haben über die pipeline
gesprochen die direkt nach deutschland
für deutschland zahlt milliarden und
abermilliarden dollar an russland wir
finden das unpassend lächerlich bisher
von flüssiggas auch energie genannt vor
allem aus norwegen und holland
aber die usa befördern seit jahren über
fracking enorme mengen konnten den
verkauf in europa um zuletzt 270 prozent
steigern
angebote aus dem mittleren osten und
afrika kommen hinzu
ist das argument einer abhängigkeit von
russland damit vom tisch
nord stream meint ja das ist die frage
denn was der markt hergibt und es ist
auch die frage wie viele hersteller von
bestimmten und lieferanten sie von
bestimmten dingen brauchen es kommt auch
keiner in deutschland auf die frage
brauchen wir nur eine autohersteller
bauen wir noch eine autotypen es ist der
markt der entscheiden wird woher das gas
kommt und da werden die russen mit
sicherheit einen signifikanten anteil
haben an den liefermengen die nach
europa kommen
aber es werden auch signifikante mengen
energie aus afrika aus arabischen
halbinsel oder aus den usa nach europa
strömen am ende ist das alles eine frage
des preises was ist der deutsche was der
europäische kunde bereit für energie zu
bezahlen und dann wird sich entscheiden
woher das gas kommt hier im russischen
gg seb gehen die arbeiten voran
zurzeit ist alles im zeitplan die zwölf
meter langen rohre mit einem durchmesser
von 1,2 metern sind bereits fast bis zum
wasser verlegt wie verändert sich der
energiemix durch flüssiggas frage ich
einen experten mit flüssiggas sagte
experte sei eben ein zusätzliches
angebot
es sei einfach eine zweite möglichkeit
der gaslieferung und des bezugs der
markt entscheiden am ende welche form
die interessantere sei gasabnehmer in
aller welt auch in europa hätten weit es
zur verfügung
je nachdem einmal pipelinegas dann
wieder flüssiggas der konsument habe am
ende die wahl zwischen flüssiggas und
pipeline gas
und das hätte auch etwas mit dem preis
zu tun ist es tatsächlich so einfach
oder ist das gas auch eine waffe moskaus
dass die russischen herrscher konflikte
nicht scheuen
haben sie bewiesen am 25 november 2008
10 konnte sind der meerenge von kertsch
in der nähe der krim zum zusammenstoß
zwischen der russischen küstenwache und
drei schiffen der ukrainischen marine
ein vorfall der sich jederzeit
wiederholen kann
seit 50 jahren liefern wir erdgas nach
europa und wir haben nie einen anlass
gegeben dass irgendwelche vorfälle
passieren in der deutschen innenpolitik
flammt die diskussion um die
abhängigkeit vom russischen gas immer
wieder auf vor allem um die interessen
der ukraine zu unterstützen
wir haben schon mehrmals erlebt dass die
russen mitten im winter bei minus 25
grad kälte den gashahn gedreht haben und
die gas lieferungen gestoppt haben
ein realistisches szenario auch für
europa wird der mix aus erdgas und
flüssiggas vorangetrieben lässt sich die
sicherheit der versorgung gewährleisten
dann ist hier die partner nord stream
aus dem russischen kind nur eine quelle
der energie aus gas und dass russland
die lieferung stoppt erscheint
unwahrscheinlich dass landes dringend
auf die staatseinnahmen angewiesen
einige hundert meter hinter mir da liegt
das schiff was die beiden teile der
pipeline zusammenführen soll
der teil der hier von land kommt aus
russland nur wenige kilometer von
estland entfernt sind wir hier und der
teil der von der see kommt aus finnland
ein kleines land hat nord stream zwei
erheblich verzögert und verteuert
dänemark denn die pipeline führt nach
den aktuellen plänen an der dänischen
insel bornholm vorbei eine entscheidung
über die genehmigung
wird von den verantwortlichen dort immer
wieder verschoben
offizieller grund sind
sicherheitsbedenken schon liegen neue
trassen vorschläge bei den dänischen
behörden vor
auf der diesjährigen volksversammlung in
born holen
mit über 100.000 teilnehmern ist noch
den 2 ein wichtiges thema
sicherheitsfragen und die mögliche
abhängigkeit von russland werden heiß
diskutiert bedroht die partner in
möglicherweise die umwelt in der ostsee
reagiert dänemark aber nur deswegen so
abwartend war das land ein wichtiger
bündnispartner der usa ist das ist
vermutlich etwas mit der creme zu tun
und etwas mit der usa zu tun
usa ist ja die wichtigste alliierte von
dänemark und ich vermute dass da ein
bisschen von die amerikaner kommt die
sagt dass das möchte man eigentlich
nicht dieser nos nimm 2 die
energie-expertin der universität in
kopenhagen bleibt jedoch dabei das
kernproblem sei die abhängigkeit von
russland es ist aktuell kein gas das für
dänemark in der pipeline transportiert
wird sagt sie
sondern es ist für europa gedacht wir
sehen russland nicht als bedrohung aber
wir machen uns sorgen um europa europa
wird dadurch abhängig von russland hat
die energie-expertin damit recht wer ist
hier von wem abhängig die usa
verschärfen mittlerweile den ton auf der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz am 16
januar 2019 erklärt vizepräsident pence
die pipeline zur bündnisfrage wir können
die verteidigung des westens nicht
garantieren wenn unsere bündnispartner
sich vom osten abhängig mache befindet
anne ist beim polen besuch am zweiten
september 2009 10 dann eine weitere
eskalation vizepräsident pence erklärt
nord stream zwei zur gefahr für die
sicherheit europas
russland versuchen die bündnispartner
auseinanderzutreiben
die wahrheit ist doch moskaus wir unser
bündnis durch öl und gas
auseinanderreißen aber sowohl polen als
auch die usa haben eine starke position
bei energetischer unabhängigkeit und
sicherheit
die usa gehen im kampf gegen nord stream
2 noch einen schritt weiter sie warnen
die beteiligten firmen
die sanktionsdrohungen betreffen
unternehmen aus norwegen den
niederlanden und deutschland
doch auch in dänemark geht es nicht
wirklich voran
wir wissen dass die den sich immer auch
im nationalen wie internationalen
gesetzesrahmen bewegen
glauben wir dass uns sehr zuversichtlich
dass das beide anträge genehmigungsfähig
sind und einer genehmigt werden wird in
der deutschen politik haben sich die
wogen dagegen geklettert alle fraktionen
im bundestag stehen inzwischen hinter
dem bau mit ausnahme von bündnis 90 die
grünen
jim ist sowohl ökologisch als auch
ökonomisch als auch europapolitischen
riesenfehler
die wichtigste aufgabe derzeit in der
europäischen politik in der außenpolitik
deutschlands ist der zusammenhalt der
europäischen union
wir reden hier über der pipeline auf
kosten von polen dem gesamten baltikum
und der ukraine und noch einigen anderen
staaten der europäischen union
und deshalb ist das fatal dass
deutschland dieses projekt so gefahren
spd-außenpolitiker niels schmidt hält
die partnern dagegen für eine hilfe bei
der energiewende
es sind sinnvolles projekt denn wir in
deutschland brauchen erdgas als
übergangstechnologie für die
energiewende
es ist allerdings wichtig es auch in
seiner politischen dimension
anzuerkennen es ist kein rein
kommerzielles projekt sondern es hat
politische auswirkungen und deshalb
müssen wir die berechtigten interessen
der ukraine berücksichtigen
in der unionsfraktion hatte es in der
vergangenheit durchaus kritik an
nordstream gegeben
inzwischen scheint man die partnern
pragmatisch zu sehen
im gegensatz zu den grünen und ihrer
kritik jogi hat außenpolitik experte der
cdu bekräftigt die positive haltung
ich bin dafür dass wir auf europäischer
ebene die frage beantworten wie wir
sicherstellen
dass wir niemals zu sehr abhängig sind
von einem gaslieferanten
das hat im übrigen gar nichts damit zu
tun wie wir politisch zu russland stehen
sondern dass es generell immer gut wenn
man mehrere optionen hat dann sind die
preise besser
die frühere litauische präsidentin frau
gruber skyter hat mal zu mir gesagt wir
haben dieses flüssiggas terminal sie
glauben gar nicht wie einfach die
vertragsverhandlungen mit gazprom irrt
sind fdp mann graf lambsdorff zuvor im
europaparlament sieht noch zu ihm zuvor
unter dem energie aspekt kritisiert dann
aber die außenpolitischen folgen
energiewirtschaftlich wird die pipeline
vermutlich von nutzen sein weil wir gas
brauchen um die energiewende zu managen
aber außenpolitisch ist sie ein
eindeutiger schaden die ukraine wird
geschwächt wir haben in der europäischen
union praktisch eine
alleinstellungsmerkmal im negativen
sinne wir sind isoliert und die
amerikaner sind auch stinksauer auf uns
die afg argumentiert mit der
energiesicherheit
sie werde durch nord stream zwei
gestärkt armin paul hampel begrüßt die
pipeline und stellt die deutschen
interessen heraus so wie auch die linken
wir wissen ja breit aufgestellt sein um
die wichtigen brennstoffe die unser land
braucht aus den unterschiedlichsten
ecken dieser welt zu bekommen wie in
ausfielen plan eine gaspipeline ist eine
variante der ressourcen die wir brauchen
und deswegen ist sie für deutschland
natürlich gut aus deutscher sicht ist es
notwendig wir haben tatsächlich durch
die energiewende in deutschland den
ausstieg aus der atomenergie den
mittelfristigen ausstieg aus der kohle
einen hohen bedarf an gas und deswegen
ist das für deutschland ein sinnvolles
projekt und deswegen finden wir es auch
wichtig für nord stream ist das argument
die ukraine sei damit ins abseits
gedrängt nicht stichhaltig das war von
anfang an so wie ich es verstanden habe
die deutsche position dass über die
köpfe der ukraine nichts passieren darf
und das entsprechend auch die transit
verträge der ukraine und auch nach dem
19 19 20 19 wenn sie auslaufen weitere
transit möglichkeiten gegeben sein soll
das ist natürlich eine politische frage
in der wir als nutzen zwei wenig zu
sagen haben aber auch ein mathematischer
gibt es sich schon aus der tatsache dass
wir in europa in den nächsten
fünf bis 15 jahren und 25 prozent import
notwendigkeit haben die durch die
heimische produktion nicht mehr gedeckt
werden kann
das heißt am ende des tages wird es auch
weiterhin einen signifikanten transit
über die ukraine geben müssen
trotz aller politischen widerstände nord
stream 2 wird kommen und nach dem 2 wird
gas von russland nach europa
transportieren
die pipeline ist für 50 jahre ausgelegt
aber im jahr 2050 wird europa co2
neutral sein wollen zumindest beheizung
und transport ob die pipeline und dann
noch gas gefördert wird das ist
zweifelhaft und wiederum eine rein
politische frage
die arbeiten am 10 milliarden euro
projekt nord stream 2 gehen unvermindert
weiter trotz aller kritik und
politischen widerstände möglicherweise
enden die diskussionen erst dann wenn
das erste gas fließt